I forget anyway just a minute okay good
afternoon everybody and I'm really proud
to join my friend and compatriot and so
many issues Congressman King now we're
here today and it's the continued
national mourning the horrible loss of
life of Americans in El Paso Texas and
Dayton Ohio we just learned the death
toll climbed with the passing of another
person in El Paso and reports like that
what you hear from the past three days
what you see on television is just
gut-wrenching poor innocent people
terrorized many killed many more
mourning those who are lost and even
those who didn't lose any loved ones the
fear the fear of what happened is real
but we're also here because these
hateful acts of violence can occur
anywhere in America anywhere
the phrase person can go online get an
idea and caused huge habit
the Walmart was in El Paso but it really
could be anywhere in America even here
as long as easy access to weapons of war
remain the unaddressed crisis we've lost
more Americans in these two days
indictment and El Paso then were lost in
Afghanistan in 2017 and 2018 combined
just think of that and their other
accidents here - they've shocked us to
the core the American gun violence
epidemic has delivered more than 250
mass shootings to this nation since the
beginning of the year El Paso and Dayton
were number 250 and number 251 they're
shooting this year that's just about one
a day
too many Americans lives have been lost
and quite frankly we're here on Long
Island and we know we've had our own
massacres and remember what happened at
the train station and several other
incidents that's were our heart set and
so we are here today well let me just
say one more thing you never really heal
and Americans more than ever are looking
behind their shoulder to see if
something if someone with a gun engaged
is potentially engaging in a mass
shooting is near so there's pain and
there's fear and today Peter King a
Republican myself the Democrat are here
to say enough is enough we are calling
on leader McConnell to bring the bill
that passed the House that Peter King
bravely sponsored to the floor of the
Senate ASAP if that bill comes to the
floor of the Senate I believe it will
pass a believable pass
Telemundo
this is the bill it's HR 8 it's a piece
of paper but it's a piece of paper that
could save lives this piece of paper
represents more than just about anything
else that could be done to stop the
violence such as occurred in Dayton and
El Paso it had bipartisan support in the
house and if leader McConnell would
simply bring this bill to the floor of
the Senate now I believe it would pass
we're saying to leader McConnell do the
right thing
gavel the Senate into an emergency
session so we can take immediate action
on the bipartisan already passed gun
legislation that Peter and others
successfully shepherded through the
House of Representatives 150 days of
slip rise since the House passed the
bill and all we've heard unfortunately
from leader McConnell to silence we can
get this done I'm the author of the
brady law back in 1993 but there are
loopholes people have gotten around the
idea that there should be background
checks I don't think almost no American
Baloo's felons should get darkness
almost no Americans believe those
adjudicated mentally ill should get
cards almost no Americans believe that
spousal abusers should get guns that's
all this bill does as all it does but it
would save a whole lot of lives on hold
no more online purchase loophole no more
gun show loophole if you want to buy a
gun you have to get a background check
that's what this law would do when we
wrote the law back in 1994 there was no
online so there was no loophole to close
gun shows were just something where
people exhibited old fashioned guns
they've now become a place where
criminals and others can buy guns and so
we have to update the law and make
America safer
90% of American support
80% of gun owners support this though
it's a very powerful lobby that fights
against it but their day has come
their day is over we can get this done
now let me fall on someone who showed
great courage in pushing this
legislation through the house and is a
colleague in asking me to join to as a
colleague and joining me and asking
leader McConnell to bring it to the door
thank you thank you very much I'm proud
to be in today with Senator Schumer any
number of bipartisan issues we agree on
work together y'all come on Iowa and
this is really working together to the
country this should not be in any way
good you know too often it becomes that
the fact is that the truck said all this
legislation does basically say that
people people who judge mental patients
have mental issues and people who are
sponsored music guilty domestic violence
will not be able to purchase a gun and
bothers me so much is when this
extension echoes in the house the number
of years before it finally got through
and the arguments you hear about it
after that people coming to your house
thank you where your guns not allowing
people to buy guns
the only people affected at all are
people in a criminal record or I've been
adjudicated as mental patient eventually
charge
so this is something there's any number
of things we can discuss about how we
can stop gun violence how we didn't stop
act is one thing we know we can do if
you do quickly this intentions which is
late it's not going to answer all of it
they only answer the small probably
don't know who do know will save life
then we'll start thinking harder harder
people who are the most dangerous
volcanoes so we can debate a lot of
things and side issues
that's what can be done and all that
should be debated but let's get one
thing done right now so that's why I
believe it's essential but Senator
McConnell allow this to come to a vote
the exemption supported we have to get
behind it this way the comfortable vote
and I think out of anything good for the
harm flat horrible tragedies of this
weekend is that we get this legislation
passed my belief is that after it is
passed no hidden bad people who say what
was the debate all about this is just
common sense that's what it common-sense
legislation
so I really appreciate truck estimated
cottages news conference today we've
shown that again how many sense people
working together and get this done and
again I call on senator mcconnell to let
it come to a vote that's all I
understand why the counters have to
control over both house I wonder stand
all that but when you have an issue with
ninety percent of the American people
one is done and the American people are
literally crying because whether it's or
this weekend to me just do the right
thing let it come to a vote in the
Senate floor and let the chips fall
where they may
I've been that good will prevail and
there you go
we'll take questions let's talk about
senator that the president who may
support some sort of gun legislation if
it's attached to immigration look we're
gonna the first job is to pass this bill
on the floor of the Senate it passed the
house just talking about closing the gun
show loopholes without any others you
had extraneous amendments it box it down
you want to get something done pass this
bill on the floor of the Senate now
yeah I was possessed the question the
nra is not alpha with the was I don't
want to you know diminish the importance
they have I think that's important go
over the heads and special-interest
right now and just appeal the American
people have the American people with
needle in their senators to get this
done without worrying about the
lobbyists that are out there yeah
there's always gonna be people against
it and they may be weaker this week you
could draw a gun actually I don't know I
just say leave all that aside and just
go on the merits with you know to power
of a powerful driving there's the latest
of many links to of many this fear and
let it come through about that's over a
sweet boy well you know there have been
some Republicans in the Senate in the
past supportive of this I think the
number will grow given what's happened
in America over the last six to eight
months in terms of the number of
tragedies that have occurred
Lederman
well my news
discussions we've discussed this long
enough this bill has bipartisan
consensus the experts the groups
everyone all believes it's the right
thing to do
discussions are fine but let's pass this
bill now we've discussed this for years
and not gotten anything done well again
you know there are lots of other things
that could be done this is number one to
Peter to me and to America let's get
this done look you know you'd have to
the idea of a red flag law is okay but
it doesn't substitute for doing this
it's not enough
I'm not gonna comment on
we're coming together right now and I
think Peter would not disagree with me
on this it would be great if president
Trump would tell leader McConnell to put
it on the floor I would say it's like
Nixon going to China President Trump
just move out and say that he believes a
background check should be held who used
to it he had both on the Senate floor
after Jenny's specific objections people
out concerned applause would get it out
but let's get this done not just the
trucks had been discussed and discussed
and discussed and today in particular
people have an issue it doesn't be able
to get it out there get it on the floor
and I think the president would just say
we need background checks and that let
me go in the Senate
leader McConnell is not putting it on
the floor that's what's holding it back
that's it thank you everybody thanks Rob